Hey youtubers it's Charlie.
Welcome to Part 2 of my Legend Of Korra Book
2 Finale.
This will be for episode 13 and 14.
So they aired it early on Nick.com and we
got a bunch of our big questions answered.
Jinora helped Korra find Raava inside of the
Dark Avatar
a new Avatar Cycle was started,
and Korra left the Spirit Portals open, allowing
Spirits to roam free going forward.
The episode also paid big reference to a major
plot point from Avatar: The Last Airbender.
I've also got details on the DVD Giveaway
I'll be doing for Book 2 as soon as they start
releasing those.
As well as the Book 3 videos that I'm going
to be doing going forward.
So be sure to SUBSCRIBE to get everything.
So let's do our TOP 5 favorite moments from
the two-part finale.
Then I'll explain some of the more technical
aspects of what happened,
especially with the energy bending.
And then I'll do my review.
Number 1 - Vaatu fused with Unalaq as predicted
forming the Dark Avatar.
They severed Korra's connection with Raava
and then destroyed her, basically erasing
her "Avatar Hard Drive" and cutting her off
from her past lives.
So I loved Unalaq during this whole sequence.
He basically became this comic book villain.
If you ever saw the 1990s Batman: The Animated
Series, he actually had "Joker-Face".
But anytime Avatar does something that it's
never done before, it's a HUGE DEAL.
And we've never seen Dark Avatar before on
the series.
Obviously after the results of the Finale,
we're not going to see another Dark Avatar
for another 10 Thousand Years at least.
But anytime they try something new, I give
them a giant HIGH FIVE!
Just to explain what happened when they fused:
So Unalaq became more of a conduit for Vaatu.
So normally you'd think that Vaatu would just
be able to sever Raava's connection on his
own.
He wouldn't need to bond with a human to do
that.
But what happens, is when a spirit bonds with
a human like Raava and Vaatu did, they gain
access to the spiritual energy.
Like when Korra was energy bending at the
end of the episode.
So it wasn't just about Unalaq becoming more
powerful, Vaatu gained access to new energy
as well.
That's how they were able to form that Super
Dark Spirit Avatar at the end.
Number 2 - Korra learns to Energy Bend with
the help of Tenzin and the Tree Of Life.
So this paid huge reference to the Avatar
Last Airbender episode from Book 2 Episode
19 "The Guru",
where Aang learns about his Chakras and learns
to connect with himself spiritually in the
way that Korra does, so she can energy bend.
So when you see her walking around in space
trying to connect with herself, that's that
Cosmic Level of Spirituality that Guru Pathik
was helping Aang with.
If you recall, Energy Bending is called the
"Lost Form of Bending", that's just because
people have forgotten how to connect with
themselves on that Cosmic Level.
But the interesting thing is that Korra still
needs Jinora's help to find the good inside
of Vaatu, to find Raava inside of Vaatu.
That basically just implies that Jinora is
the most powerful spiritual person on Korra
right now.
Or at least the most in tune with her spirituality.
Number 3 - Korra defeats Vaatu and Unalaq
or the Dark Avatar.
However you want to think of him, killing
Unalaq in the process.
And basically supressing Vaatu for another
10 Thousand Years.
So we will not see a Dark Avatar again because
Unalaq was killed while they were in the Avatar
State.
He's basically dead, he's not coming back.
The cycle of resurrection will not happen.
But over the next 10 Thousand Years, Vaatu
will slowly grow out of Raava.
So whoever is the Avatar in 10 Thousand Years
will basically have to go through all this
again.
Especially if Vaatu tries to form another
Dark Avatar.
Number 4 - Raava is pulled out of Korra and
basically suppressed or destroyed temporarily,
erasing Korra's Avatar hard drive.
So all those past lives, those past Avatars
weren't destroyed in the process.
They're just cut off from Korra now.
So they're people talking to spirits all the
time in the world of Avatar, the Last Airbender
as well as Legend of Korra.
So they're still out there.
They're just living in the giant Spiritual
Data Cloud now with Guru Pathik.
So Korra just doesn't have direct and constant
access to them like she did when she was Avatar.
All that means is that she is basically starting
a New Cycle of Avatars.
Just like Wan did when he first bonded with
Raava.
So essentially she's the "First Avatar" of
a new line of Avatars.
And Number 5 - Korra left the Spirit Portals
open, allowing spirits to pass in to the physical
realm and roam free with humans.
So this is going to figure in Books 3 and
4.
But now, spirits will be roaming everywhere.
So we will definitely be seeing a lot of old
spirits come back in Book 3 and Book 4.
So if you have any favorite spirits like the
face of Koh, they'll probably come back in
Book 3 and 4.
Book 3 by the way is also an Earth Kingdom
book, they're going to be dealing with a lot
of Earth Kingdom stories.
Just like Avatar Last Airbender, so it's all
about cycles.
But what did I think of the Finale?
Overall Beginnings is still my favorite episode
of Legend of Korra of all time.
But I really liked the way that the Finale
paid off a lot of classic stories like "The
Guru" as well as answering a lot of our big
questions.
And giving us an interesting to go in Books
3 and 4.
Especially with all the spirits flying around
now.
The only thing I thought they could have done
better, was explain a little bit more about
the technical aspects of what Korra was doing
with her powers in this Final Battle.
So, just because Korra became the Avatar,
she was born as the Avatar as a baby, did
not mean she automatically knew how to use
all of her powers instantly.
And basically, in this episode she learns
to Energy Bend within like 2 minutes.
And automatically knows how to use all of
those powers.
So that's my only small complaint, it's not
a big complaint.
But this is only because Avatar Legend of
Korra has half the number of episodes that
Avatar Last Airbender had to tell the same
story.
But let me know in the comments, "What Are
Your Favorite Moments from the Finale?"
as well as your general thoughts on Book 2
as a whole.
I'll be doing another separate video, just
to review Book 2 as a whole next week.
Be sure to SUBSCRIBE to get it!
They're going to be airing the Finale again
on TV.
So here's the details on my Korra Book 2 DVD
Giveaway.
As well as my Book 3 videos.
So they haven't announced a release date for
the Book 2 DVD yet, but as soon as they do
I'll be giving away a couple free copies.
And I'll be doing a weekly Korra video going
forward every week until we get to Book 3.
So if you've ever seen any of my Game Of Thrones
videos, you know that I do a lot of Game of
Thrones even though there's no Game Of Thrones
on TV right now.
So I'll be doing the same thing with Korra.
I'll also be looking for a new Anime or Animation
show to do based on your guys' recommendations.
Be sure to let me know in the comments!
What do you think I should start doing videos
for?
It can be anything like "One Piece" or "Naruto"
but I just ask that it be relatively NEW and
COMING SOON.
Right now CLICK HERE to get my PART 1 video
for the Legend of Korra Finale.
And CLICK HERE to learn all about my Doctor
Who 50th Anniversary DVD Giveaway.
Thank You so much for watching.
HIGH FIVES!
See you guys TONIGHT!